au lever du jour ce quartier de la ville
et dévasté
[Musique]
respecter l'ordre et c'est tout donc moi
ça explique pas tout ça c'est impossible
presque tout à brûlé et j'en suis tout
ému
c'est un super marché qui brûle encore
ce matin
à Tourcoing une école en grande partie
détruite par les flammes
[Musique]
génération
un peu plus loin à Clamart c'est un
tramway qui a été incendié alors de
partir au travail beaucoup d'usagers
sont dépités
qu'on prenne les gens en otage comme ça
il y aura peut-être d'autres façons de
discuter sur le ce genre de problème que
de mettre des gens dans l'embarras pour
aller travailler le matin
dans de nombreuses villes des voitures
brûlées des bâtiments publics dégradés
alors aujourd'hui évidemment on l'a tous
noté c'est le 73e jour d'apaisement
plus que 27 jours d'apaisement à tenir
c'était plus calme quand la France était
pas apaisée je trouve derrière il y a
une crise malgré tout de l'intégration
d'une partie des immigrés qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans les mœurs dans
les coutumes
français français
même à 2000% ils sont français ils sont
je parle je n'ai pas dit qu'il n'était
pas français je vous dis qu'une partie
immigrés pour l'Insee c'est les immigrés
et leur descendants
oui une super idée d'avoir découvert ça
à travers la pandémie de découvrir la
France et de découvrir l'intérieur du
pays passe le tout et toujours en mer
aussi les vacances orthophoniques
afin de mieux vous adapter dans votre
pays merci Bernard à partir du moment où
l'État ne peut pas protéger c'est bien
et les personnes puisque on a sûrement
éviter un drame avec l'incendie sur un
balcon qui s'est propagé jusqu'au 6e
étage d'un immeuble quatre personnes
quatre personnes blessées oui le
contrôle c'est quand on est on empêche
ce genre de choses nous ne sommes pas
capables aujourd'hui ou alors
voulons-nous réellement empêcher cela et
[Musique]
le jour des gloires est arrivé
aujourd'hui la France a peur des
délinquants c'est une réalité on laisse
des délinquants brûler le bien commun
brûler la voiture de l'ouvrier parce que
l'on s'écartait là ce sont pas des PDG
c'est pas le PDG de Total qui habite la
Garges-lès-Gonesse ou à bois Sarcelles
donc voilà les gens qui se mettent se
sont réveillés ils voulaient aller
travailler ils avaient leur voiture
calcinée voilà aujourd'hui l'État n'est
plus en mesure de protéger les citoyens
nos concitoyens après 48 heures
d'enquête le procureur de Nanterre a
tranché le policier auteur du tir mortel
fait désormais l'objet d'une information
judiciaire pour homicide volontaire le
parquet considère que les conditions
légales d'usage de l'arme ne sont pas
réunis une autre enquête est ouverte
pour fond en écriture dans cette affaire
le policier pourrait écoper d'une
seconde mise en examen car dans ses
premières déclarations mentionnées sur
PV il a affirmé avoir tiré alors que le
véhicule je cite
sur lui est-ce que tu sais pourquoi ça
s'est embrasé puisqu'il y a certaines
personnes qui ont un grand taux d'imat
qui ont lancé sur les réseaux et sur les
plateaux mais les messiers et compagnie
par jour
qui est fait pour décrédibiliser le
gamin Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est c'est un appel à l'insurrection
que ce tweet les chiens de garde nous
ordonnent d'appeler au calme nous
appelons à la justice retirer l'action
judiciaire contre le pauvre Naël
suspendait le policier meurtrier son
complice qui lui a ordonné de tirer
foutez la paix à l'ambulancier moi je
n'appelle pas ou calme j'appelle à la
justice et d'ajouter ce sont les
policiers qui doivent se calmer quelques
heures plus tôt c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui évoquait une police incontrôlée par
le pouvoir de son côté la secrétaire
nationale de reprise Écologie Les Verts
dénonce un problème système de racisme
dans la police a contrario il y a le
député européen les républicains
François-Xavier Bellamy qui estiment que
si ce jeune est mort il parle de Naël
c'est d'abord parce qu'il a cherché à se
soustraire à un contrôle il y a des
pseudos et je dis bien pseudo
journaliste qui ont commencé à attiser
sur les réseaux la haine qui a commencé
à attiser la discorde qui ont commencé à
un peu chauffer la marmite pour que ça
se tape dessus d'accord et moi je donne
des noms les Messia et les compagnies
qui te disent qu'ils sont en train de te
parler de tolérance de la langue il y a
des footballeurs qui se sont mis dans le
jeu donc tout ça ça a fait quoi ça fait
bouillir la marmite Si Omar Sy réclame
une justice digne de ce nom pour honorer
la mémoire de cet enfant et si Kylian
Mbappe évoque un petit ange parti
beaucoup trop tôt d'autres sont plus
virulents comme Jules Kunde le défenseur
des Bleus déplore une bavure policière
et accuse les chaînes d'information en
continu de déformer la vérité et de
criminaliser la victime et un président
qui te dit c'est inexcusable et et et
responsables politiques le problème
c'est que c'est que tout le monde est en
train de rajouter sa pièce dans le
jukebox pour continuer à marcher
d'accord mais comment on fait maintenant
alors au lieu de cette frénésie
médiatique de cette justice médiatique
d'accord on laisse redescendre un peu la
pression mais comment on tout simplement
en arrêtant de
surenchérir sur ça je vous trouve
extraordinaire ah merci j'aime bien
vraiment vous me posez une question
à laquelle vous savez par définition que
je ne peux pas répondre
et donc vous mettez en porte-à-faux
parce que vous
déclamez votre votre chronique
d'excellente facture bien écrit et moi
je vous réponds mais je peux pas vous
répondre
pour un président de
de la gendarmerie ou les forces de
sécurité en disant moi président de la
République
j'autorise les forces de l'ordre à
ouvrir le feu sur toute personne qui
grillera un barrage de police
ça donne le sentiment que vous avez
raison vous vous défilez
de d'interpellation
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi vous me
demandez si on a détourné une procédure
pour étoffer un dossier pour étoffer un
dossier et pardon j'ai dit tout à
l'heure la Constitution m'interdisait
de commenter une affaire en cours on est
dans une politique totale de bisounours
d'attentisme
ça n'est plus possible j'ai l'impression
que vous êtes au bord du burnout moi je
vais vous prescrire une petite retraite
ça va être très bien